[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend in allen ich bin sehr froh
dass sie Zeit fanden hierher zu kommen
sagt der eine sie sind mein lieber
Freund sagt der andere der eine will
zeigen dass er noch Verbündete hat in
der Welt obwohl ein internationaler
Haftbefehl gegen ihn vorliegt der andere
gibt sich als Diplomat und
Friedensbringer so viel Symbolik da
müssen die ganz großen Bilder her
goldene Türen
endlose Teppiche Vladimir Putin Ping
zwei Staatenlenker einig auf Augenhöhe
das ist die Inszenierung
[Musik]
tatsächlich besucht hier einen Despot
den anderen der immer stärker von ihm
abhängig wird im und Export von und nach
China sind für Russlands Wirtschaft
überlebenswichtig geworden und auch der
Westen guckt gespannt auf das Schauspiel
dass sie da in Moskau geben wird picking
auch Waffen liefern Sebastian eben
berichtet
diese Brücke ist ein Symbol für die
russisch-chinesische Freundschaft in
blavaviercinsk sieben Flugstunden
entfernt von Moskau trennt nur der Fluss
Amur die beiden Großmächte doch das
Verhältnis von China und Russland
verändert sich Peking wird immer
einflussreicher hier an der Grenze ist
China schon seit Jahrzehnten
allgegenwärtig Russen und Chinesen leben
arbeiten und Handeln hier Hand in Hand
wir haben eine enge Freundschaft mit
China hier in unseren Hochschulen sind
auch viele chinesische Studenten
was spricht denn dagegen ein starkes
Land zum Freund zu haben
wie sehr Vladimir Putin gerade einen
starken Freund braucht zeigt ja pompöse
Empfang den er hier in pingen heute
Nachmittag im Kreml bereitet die
gewaltigen Flaggen Sinnbild für die
großen gemeinsamen Pläne Russland
braucht Peking um die westlichen
Sanktionen im Land abzuschwächen vor
allem die Einnahmen aus dem Gasgeschäft
Putin verkündet heute den Bau der neuen
Pipeline Richtung China stehen nichts
mehr im Wege den Westen brauche Russland
nicht so Putins Botschaft
wir vertiefen unsere Kooperation wir
haben Erfahrungen mit zivilem Flugzeug
und Schiffsbau in unserem Land genau wie
mit der Automobilproduktion wir sind
bereit auch chinesische Firmen dabei zu
unterstützen mit ihren Fabriken die
westlichen zu ersetzen die Russland
verlassen haben Russland bindet sich
immer stärker an China und wird so immer
abhängiger vor dem Besuch keimte
Hoffnung auf das hi seinen Einfluss
geltend machen könnte und Putin zum
Einlenken in der Ukraine zu bewegen doch
heute blieb hier genau wie der
chinesische zwölf Punkteplan für Frieden
im Ungefähren
in der Frage der ukraine-krise hat sich
China stets an die Grundsätze der
Charter der Vereinten Nationen gehalten
eine objektive und unparteiische
Position eingenommen und sich aktiv für
Frieden eingesetzt
wie genau der Frieden aussehen könnte
sagte ich ihn nicht und auch Putin ließ
kein Entgegenkommen erkennen er
kritisierte stattdessen westliche
Waffenlieferungen
es sieht so aus als ob der Westen
tatsächlich beabsichtigt Russland zu
bekämpfen bis der letzte Ukraine Tod ist
sie bekämpfen uns nicht mit Worten
sondern mit Taten in diesem Zusammenhang
möchte ich anmerken dass Russland
reagieren wird wenn der kollektive
Westen beginnt Nuklearwaffen einzusetzen
bei Wein Heilbutt aus Murmansk und
Rindersteak senden China und Russland am
Abend eine Botschaft der Freundschaft in
die Welt es scheint als Sätze Vladimir
Putin alles auf seinen starken Freund
ja Micro hohe Tari ist Direktor des
mercator-instituts für China Studien und
jetzt bei uns willkommen zurück im
heutigen Abend guten Abend da basteln
zwei die Menschenrechte mit Füßen treten
an einer wie sie selbst sagen neuen
Weltordnung wie viel Sorge muss uns
dieser Tag machen wir müssen das schon
sehr ernst nehmen Präsident Parteien
Staatschef sie dem Ping in Moskau mit
klaren Signalen dass er den Rücken von
Putin freihält und entsprechend
zum eigenen Interesse auch versucht
Geschäfte voranzutreiben die
strategische Beziehung zu vertiefen und
ganz klar ausgedrückt in der gemeinsamen
Ablehnung der Ordnung für die der besten
steht international das ist schon ein
Zeichen und ähm wir müssen genau
hinhören was die Signale sind
es ist überraschend in welcher
Deutlichkeit ist sie sich dort durchaus
auch feiern lässt in Moskau dann gucken
wir doch vielleicht mal auf diese
verschiedene Signale die da heute
gesendet wurden zunächst mal für
Vladimir Putin scheint das ja sowas zu
sein wie eine ja eine Versicherung dass
er im Amt bleiben kann als russischer
Präsident hier hat ihn heute gleich mal
so nebenbei zum Gewinner der nächsten
russischen Wahlen erklärt das
bemerkenswert also in der Tat
so eine deutlich Unterstützung von Putin
zeigt doch auch noch mal woran es viel
gelegen ist es geht um Putins Russland
dass er unterstützt das ist diese tiefe
auch enge Verbindung die die beiden
Führer miteinander haben über ja Jahre
mittlerweile aufgebaut und sie setzt auf
Putin das hat er hätte er fast
deutlicher nicht machen können heute
werden wir mal einen Moment ziemlich
weit zurückgehen in der Geschichte dann
gibt es die gerade zu legendäre
Erzählung wie Mao auf Besuch in der
Sowjetunion damals war und Stalin ihm
gut zwei Wochen lang in einer Dacia
warten ließ bis es dann ein Gespräch gab
einzige Abwechslung übrigens soll eine
kaputte Tischtennisplatte gewesen sein
das hat sich ja definitiv gründlich
geändert jetzt ist Putin abhängig von
hier in wie weit nutzt China das aus
also schon eine sehr deutliche Umkehr
der Verhältnisse putin ist jemand der
gerne warten lässt aber sie ganz
bestimmt nicht und
die Verhältnisse sind klar Putin muss
viel stärker noch wirtschaftlich auf
China setzen hat deutliche Angebote
gemacht Vertiefung immer Energie Sektor
gemeinsam Interessen bei der
Entflechtung der Welt vom US-Dollar und
dann eben auch auf den Jörn die
chinesische Währung zu setzen und nicht
mehr den Rubel im übrigen und dann auch
noch das Angebot im Bereich der
Agrarwirtschaft noch stärker auf
Entwicklung hin und mit China und
Lieferung nach China zu setzen das ist
noch kein Ausverkauf der russischen
Wirtschaft aber es hat schon ganz klare
Richtung mittlerweile manche sagen schon
das ist bereits neues Vasallentum die
Inszenierung heute allerdings war und da
viele doch auf immer ganz gleichrangig
quasi oder das ist der große
diplomatische Kuh der China seit langem
gelingt mit Russland und sie
insbesondere
das ist ein Spiel auf Augenhöhe so wird
das signalisiert nur unter den
Bedingungen spielt Putin natürlich auch
mit das wirkt nach außen am stärksten
und am stabilsten und nicht nur das Ego
von Putin sondern sicherlich auch
sozusagen der Anschein dieser
strategischen Tiefe wird dadurch gewahrt
ohne dass würde das nicht so gut
funktionieren jetzt haben wir schon viel
über Wirtschaft geredet wir beiden hier
wir müssen aber auch noch über ein sehr
hoch brisantes Thema reden indem ich das
militärische die NATO sagt wir haben
Anzeichen dass Russland lethal eight aus
China erbeten habe also Waffenhilfe wenn
das so war wie würden Sie sagen hat
China reagiert
nun erstmal geht es glaube ich einen
Schritt zurück zu machen wir wissen dass
China unterhalb dieser Schwelle
im Bereich der Dual use Lieferungen im
Bereich der
militärlogistikbereich bereits aktiv ist
also sprich Dinge die man auch als
Waffen verwenden kann die als
Jagdgewehre deklariert werden können
oder schwere Laster die eben in deutlich
größerer Zahl geliefert werden weil
Russland sie für die kriegslogistik
benötigt also das ist durchaus jetzt
schon der Fall diese rote Linie zu
überschreiten jetzt hartes Kriegsgerät
zu liefern da wird cheese sehr sehr
vorsichtig weiterhin kalibrieren weil
natürlich unterschiedliche Interessen
hier verfolgt stand jetzt gelingt ihm
das ganz gut der Westen hat bislang
nicht zu Sanktionen oder härteren
Maßnahmen gegenüber China getroffen und
zögert dann natürlich auch gleichzeitig
ähm scheint ja die Unterstützung für
Russland so weit zu gelingen bislang das
zumindest die Aussicht besteht das Putin
sich weiterhalten und durchsetzen kann
dann schließt sich natürlich noch die
wichtige Frage an was heißt denn diese
enge Zusammenarbeit Russland und China
jetzt für die Ukraine oder anders
gefragt kann China überhaupt noch sowas
wie ein neutraler Vermittler in der in
dem Krieg in dem Konflikt sein
keinesfalls ein neutraler Vermittler das
ist auch nicht die Botschaft die da
gesendet wird ganz klar aus dem zwölf
Punkte Friedensplan ja auch
zurückgegangen wegen China dafür die
Hauptursache des Konfliktes sieht der
aggresso Russland wird nicht benannt es
wird sozusagen auf beiden Seiten die
Verantwortung gesucht
es steht ein Telefonat an offensichtlich
mit Präsident zu Linz gehen in der
Ukraine das ist gut das ist wichtig aber
wir sind weit davon entfernt das Peking
hier im Interesse der Ukraine und auch
natürlich im europäischen Interesse hier
mittelfristig einen echte
Vermittlungsleistung bringen könnte
können auch nicht neutrale Vermittler am
Ende etwas erreichen
in dieser Partie gibt es fast niemand
mehr der der vollkommen neutral ist und
es wird notwendig sein dass auch Akteure
dieses Konflikts zusammenkommen insofern
China wird Fingerabdrücke auf diesem
Konflikt hinterlassen und wir müssen
auch sicherstellen dass die
Gesprächskanäle offen bleiben aber noch
mal Prinzip Hoffnung ist dir glaube ich
nicht angesagt dass es eine ganz klare
einseitige Interessen Politik die dort
auch verfolgt wird interessant Analyse
sehr hohe Tarif vielen Dank danke
und so viel zunächst heute Abend zu
diesem Thema und da kommt unser nächstes
wir gehen nach Deutschland sie sind sich
nicht mehr grün in der Berliner
Regierungskoalition vor zwei Wochen bei
der gemeinsamen Klausurtagung auf
Schloss Meseberg hieß es noch das waren
konstruktive Beratungen und ein sehr
fühlbares unterhaken Zitat Olaf Scholz
heute zeigen sich die Grünen auf ihrer
eigenen Klausurtagung in Weimar massiv
unzufrieden mit der aktuellen Arbeit der
Ampel und sie zeigen dabei vor allem auf
die FDP die Nerven liegen einigermaßen
blank am Sonntag will und muss ein
Koalitionsausschuss Lösungen liefern
Vergleich eine ganze Reihe von offenen
Fragen Ines Trams mit mehr
es ist der neueste Streitpunkt innerhalb
der Ampel die Grünen wollen den
Kohleausstieg koste es was es wolle auch
in den ostdeutschen Ländern acht Jahre
früher als geplant nämlich bis 2030 FDP
und SPD gehen da nicht mit doch mit
Blick auf das Klima und die Menschen in
der Region argumentieren die Grünen das
marktwirtschaftlich bedingt durch den
europäischen Emissionszertifikate Handel
sehr wahrscheinlich auch so Schluss sein
wird vor 2030 mit der Kohle dann aber
ungeplant dann überraschend für die
Menschen und unser Versprechen ist lasst
uns das gemeinsam machen das Strahlen
auf der Klausur der grünen
Bundestagsfraktion etwas gewollt sie
drängen auf mehr Klimaschutz doch FDP
auch SPD bremsen so das Gefühl hier in
weima Minister Habeck verteidigt seinen
Vorstoß ab nächstem Jahr neue Gas und
Ölheizungen zu verbieten die FDP will
das nicht
wer Gasheizung hat oder Ölheizung hat
der darf sie weiter haben niemand geht
in den Keller und reist die raus wer
kaputte Ölheizung oder Gasheizung hat
der kann sie heile machen und zwar nicht
nur einmal sondern so lange wie es
irgendwie geht
wärmewende und der Austausch von
Heizungen das Aus für den
Verbrennermotor der Bau neuer Autobahnen
die Liste der streith Themen der Grünen
mit dem Rest der Ampel ist lang
dünnhäutig kritisieren sie ihre Partner
Klimaschutz dürfen nicht zum Kulturkampf
werden es kann aber nicht sein dass in
einer fortschrittskoalition nur einen
Koalitionspartner für den Fortschritt
verantwortlich ist und die anderen für
die Verhinderung von Fortschritt für
eine Bundestagswahl die
nachher die Politikerin und die
Politiker belohnt die am wenigsten
Probleme gelöst haben
ich glaube da haben wir keinen Bock
drauf konkret ihre Kritik an
Verkehrsminister Wissing er würde
Klimaschutz im Verkehr vernachlässigen
wolle neben Brücken und Bahnstrecken
auch neue Autobahnen bauen wir haben ein
Verkehrsminister der ist aktuell nicht
als seinen Job ansieht Vorschläge zu
machen wie man dieses Problem löst am
Ende verantwortet das aber eine gesamte
Bundesregierung verantwortet das auch
ein Kanzler dass wir Klimaschutz
schaffen auch im Verkehrssektor und
darüber werden wir reden am Wochenende
klingt als erwarteten die Grünen von
Kanzler Scholz ein erneutes Machtwort am
Sonntag beim Koalitionsausschuss in
Berlin wenn die streithemen auf dem
Tisch liegen
ja wir bleiben noch Moment an diesem
Dienstag und kommen mit zu einem Urteil
über dem dieselfahrerinnen und Fahrer
aufhorchen dürften jetzt bei dir Anna ja
es ist ein wegweisendes Urteil des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs zum
dieselabgas-skandal während Fahrzeug
besitzt in dem eine unzulässige
abschalteinrichtung verbaut wurde kann
künftig leichter Schadensersatz
verlangen denn das EuGH hat entschieden
dass Autohersteller auch dann haften
können wenn sie ohne Betrugsabsicht und
nur fahrlässig gehandelt haben konkret
geht es um Motoren die die
Abgasreinigung bei bestimmten
Temperaturen ausschalten Gerichte müssen
nun im Einzelfall klären ob
Schadensersatz gezahlt wird und wie hoch
dieser ausfällt
im Streit ist
Bundesverkehrsministeriums und der
EU-Kommission über das Verbrenner aus im
Jahr 2035 gibt es ein Kompromissangebot
laut einem Entwurf schlägt die
EU-Kommission Verkehrsminister Wissing
darin vor dass sie Autos mit
Verbrennermotor weiter zulassen will
wenn sie ausschließlich mit sogenannten
efuels betrieben werden können eine
Einigung dazu gibt es weiterhin nicht
wissen erklärte dass er an einer
schnellen Klärung interessiert sei die
aber belastbar und verbindlich sein
müssen dies werde gerade sorgfältig
geprüft
in Frankreich hat das erneut heftige
Proteste gegen die beschlossene
Rentenreform gegeben nachdem die
Regierung gestern zwei
misstrauensanträge im Parlament
überstanden hatte teilweise schlugen
Demonstrationen in Krawalle um die
polizeinahmen allein in Paris mehr als
200 Menschen fest Gewerkschaften riefen
dazu auf die Streiks etwa bei der
Müllabfuhr und an Raffinerien zu
verstärken beim Benzin kommt es zu
ersten Engpässen Präsident macron will
sich morgen im Fernsehen an die Nation
wenden
Bundesbildungsministerin stark Watzinger
hat als erstes deutsches
Regierungsmitglied seit 26 Jahren Taiwan
besucht in Taipeh unterzeichneten
Vertreter Deutschlands und Taiwans ein
Kooperationsabkommen im
Technologiebereich da waren sei ein
wichtiger Partner betonte die Ministerin
gerade mit Blick auf Batterie und
Halbleitertechnologie und bei grünem
Wasserstoff china reagierte mit scharfer
Kritik auf den Besuch der deutschen
Ministerin die Volksrepublik betrachtet
den Inselstaat als abtrünniges Gebiet
am Wochenende war der 45 Präsident der
Vereinigten Staaten beim College Ringen
in Oklahoma und ungefähr so sieht Donald
Trump offenbar auf seine
Auseinandersetzung mit der Justiz am
Dienstag soll ich festgenommen werden
hatte Trump angekündigt und gleichzeitig
seine Anhänger aufgefordert dagegen zu
protestieren
heute ist Dienstag bislang gibt es keine
Hinweise dass Trump festgenommen wurde
im Raum steht aber tatsächlich eine
mögliche Anklage gegen ihn das wäre
historisch gegen einen früheren
Präsidenten hat es so etwas in der
Geschichte noch nie gegeben drei Fragen
dazu an unseren Washington
Korrespondenten Elma teven guten Abend
Elmar erste Frage absehbar ob
tatsächlich eine Festnahme bevorsteht
ist das absehbar ein Trump in
Handschellen
also eine Anklage könnte in den nächsten
Tagen kommen Handschellen eher
unwahrscheinlich weil wir hören dass
Donald Trump freiwillig kommen würde
nach New York dann würde er natürlich
ganz normal seine Fingerabdrücke abgeben
müssen es würden Fotos gemacht und der
würde vor dem Haftrichter
höchstwahrscheinlich in Anzug und
Krawatte und eben nicht im
Häftlingskleidung dann auf nicht
schuldig plädieren dann kam er wieder
frei nur wenn er sich weigert nach New
York zu kommen dann müsste man ihn holen
und das obwohl ja Secret Service Agenten
nach wie vor rund um den Ex-Präsidenten
sind was steckt dahinter dieser
möglichen Anklage um was geht's da
ja die Pornodarstellerin Stefanie
Clifford alias stormy Daniels hat im
Jahr 2016 kurz vor der
Präsidentschaftswahl damit gedroht mit
einer kurzen Affäre die sie mit Trump 10
Jahre vorher hatte an die Öffentlichkeit
zu gehen der Anwalt von Donald Trump
Michael Kohn hat dann offenbar ein
Schweigegeld gezahlt von 130.000 Dollar
Trump hat die Vorwürfe später als sie
bekannt wurden dann bestritten aber
mittlerweile gilt die Zahlung als
gesichert und ganz offenbar hat Trump
diese Kosten dann verdreifacht und als
Anwaltskosten angegeben steuerlich
abgesetzt Steuern gespart und er hätte
sie als Wahlkampf Unterstützung angeben
müssen darum dreht sich diese Klage
wahrscheinlich und am Ende drohen ihm
dann entweder Bußgeld und Bewährung oder
bis zu vier Jahre Haft und was will
Trump erreichen mit dieser Ankündigung
er werde festgenommen und im Aufruf an
seine Anhänger
naja er will die erregungskultur
befeuern und politisch und finanziell
davon zu profitieren die Tatsache dass
wir zwei gerade darüber reden zeigt ja
dass das ganz offenbar funktioniert und
ich will mal zeigen hier gibt es eine
E-Mail die Donald Trump verschickt da
ist ein Foto zu sehen von den
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen in New York und
unten kann man per Knopfdruck dann
spenden 25 bis 250 $ oder beliebiger
andere Summen also er macht im Grunde
genommen Wahlkampf als verfolgte
Unschuld und bekommt dabei auch noch
Unterstützung von seinen Parteifreunden
dabei geht es ja in diesem Verfahren und
auch in einigen noch viel ernster zu
nehmenden Verfahren ja am Ende darum ob
ein Ex-Präsident über den Gesetz steht
oder eben nicht die US-Justiz und ihre
Versuche Donald Trump zu fassen zu
bekommen drei Fragen danke Elmar für die
drei Antworten
und damit zurück zu uns nach Deutschland
was sollte
Pflichtlektüre sein in der Schule was
Stoff fürs Abi die Diskussion darum ist
so alt wie der Deutschunterricht selbst
und sie verläuft quer durch alle rein
Schülerinnen und Schüler Lehrerinnen und
Lehrer die Kultusministerien in
Baden-Württemberg kocht aktuell ein
Streit bei dem es vordergründig um ein
Stück deutscher Nachkriegsliteratur geht
den Roman Tauben im Gras von Wolfgang
Köppen tatsächlich aber geht es um
Grundsätzliches um die Frage nämlich wie
wird man einem Werk gerecht das immer
auch Dokument seiner Epoche ist
einerseits dessen Sprache aber
andererseits heute befremdet verstört
entsetzt kann das guter Stoff sein um
Rassismus im Unterricht zu behandeln
Petra Otto und Anna Gürth berichten
dieses Buch wird sie auf gar keinen Fall
im Unterricht durchnehmen obwohl es auf
dem Lehrplan steht für das Abi nächstes
Jahr als wichtiges Werk deutscher
Nachkriegsliteratur gilt gar als
Rassismus kritisch für Jasmin bland ist
Tauben im Gras das Gegenteil ein
rassistisches Buch mehr als 100 Mal muss
sie darin das ein Wort lesen längst
verpönte es auszusprechen diese
abschätzige Bezeichnung für schwarze
Menschen
mich hat es wirklich getroffen ich
dachte mir wirklich das kann nicht sein
dass das eine Lektüre ist die man jetzt
im Unterricht behandeln soll es gibt
auch andere Werke mit denen man
wahnsinnig gut Rassismus aufarbeiten
kann ohne dass man eine Gruppe die
humanisiert viele mögen diese
Sprachempfinden nicht nachvollziehen
doch als bloße Befindlichkeit einer
betroffenen lasse sich die Kritik nicht
abtun meint der Sprachwissenschaftler
Daniel Gutmann das endwort sei nicht
irgendein Schimpfwort das Besondere an
diesem Wort ist dass das einfach der
Ausdruck ist der dieses größten Grad an
Tabuisierungen erfahren hat und jede
neue Verwendung aktiviert in gewisse
Hinsicht die ganze
diskriminierungsgeschichte die mit dem
Wort verknüpft ist nämlich die
Geschichte der Sklaverei der Macht
weißer über schwarze der
rassismusforscher Karim veredoni hält
Vorträge zu Rassismus in der Schule und
er versteht nicht warum gerade dieses
Buch zur Diskussion Rassismus geeignet
sein soll beim N-Wort zähle die Wirkung
nicht die Absicht egal wie es gemeint
ist der größte Teil der Bevölkerung hat
das eben nicht als problematisch
wahrgenommen aber ich würde sagen schon
immer waren rassistische Wörter in
Klassikern problematisch und ich finde
das gut dass die Lehrerin Frau bland
sich dagegen wehrt er hat die Petition
das Buch vom Lehrplan zu nehmen mit
unterzeichnet doch köppens Tauben im
Gras soll Abi Stoff bleiben das hat die
baden-württembergische Kultusministerin
so entschieden auch weil es in einigen
Schulen bereits behandelt werde
ich glaube dass wir es wirklich mit der
Einordnung und mit der zwingenden
Diskussion über Rassismus an der Stelle
zu reden das ist einfach noch mal ein
gutes Beispiel ist um zu zeigen wie
Sprache einerseits sich verändert hat
wie Einschätzung sich auch verändert hat
und wie man heutzutage mit Menschen
andere Hautfarbe umgeht Jasmin blond ist
enttäuscht und sie ist konsequent hat
für nächste Schuljahr eine Beurlaubung
beantragt
so Hanna jetzt noch mal du mit unserem
großen Thema von gestern und den Folgen
heute ganz genau nach der notübernahme
der Credit Suisse durch die UBS stehen
die Zeichen an den Aktienmärkten heute
auf Erholung doch Risiken für das
Bankensystem bleiben Frank Bethmann
darauf hat unter anderem die EZB Banken
auf sich hingewiesen welche sind das
genau ja die europäische Bankenaufsicht
hat gesagt dass nach krisenreichen
Monaten die Zahlungsausfälle bei Banken
zunehmen also das Unternehmen oder auch
Privatpersonen ihre Kredite nicht mehr
zurückzahlen können und dass die
Geldhäuser nun aufpassen müssten sollte
die so weitergehen dass sie nicht in
Schwierigkeiten geraten die Behörde
ermahnte die Geschäftsbanken zu einer
erhöhten Wachsamkeit vor allem zu einem
Nachschärfen des Risikomanagement dort
sehen die auch sehr noch viel Luft nach
oben im Fokus vor allem
Immobilienkredite und Kredite von
hochverschuldeten Unternehmen die
Warnung heute sicher keinen Zufall
wenige Tage nach dem Banken Beben und
einem weiteren absprechen der Kultur
deuten die Aufseher nun an dort wo es
nötig ist die Daumenschrauben anzuziehen
belasten die Turbulenzen bei den Banken
die Konjunktur denn bereits zusätzlich
ja ganz klar sagen die vom Zentrum für
europäische Wirtschaftsforschung
Befragten Finanzanalysten die
Unsicherheit an den Finanzmärkten seinen
nach wie vor hoch das drücke auf die
Konjunkturerwartungen wobei sie
präzisieren es sei derzeit weniger die
Furcht vor weiteren Banken Schieflagen
viel mehr bestünde die Sorge dass die
Banken nun bei neuen Krediten sehr viel
genauer hinschauen werden wem sie noch
Geld leihen und wem nicht und weniger
Kreditgeschäft bremst normal das
Wirtschaftswachstum die Erholung heute
hier deshalb vielleicht nur von kurzer
Dauer vielen Dank für diese Analyse
tausende Ärztinnen und Ärzte ließen
heute ihre Arbeit ruhen sie beteiligten
sich in mehreren Bundesländern am
Warnstreik der Ärzte Gewerkschaft
Marburger Bund wie hier in Hamburg
Gewerkschaft fordert für die rund 55.000
Ärztinnen und Ärzte an kommunalen
Krankenhäusern einen Inflationsausgleich
und eine Gehaltserhöhung von
2,5%. am 30 März soll wieder gestreikt
werden
der Deutsche Wetterdienst hat in seiner
Bilanz zum Jahr 2022 vor den Folgen des
Klimawandels gewarnt mit 2024 Stunden
war das vergangene Jahr das
sonnenreichste seit Beginn der
Erhebungen die Folgen der Erderwärmung
würden zunehmend negativ spürbar auch
stark und Dauerregen gehörten bereits
jetzt zu den schadenreichsten
Wetterphänomenen in Deutschland deren
Gefahren würden mit steigenden
Temperaturen weiter zunehmen erklärten
die Meteorologen
und auch das ist eine Folge der
Erderwärmung vier von fünf Bäumen in
Deutschland sind mittlerweile krank zu
diesem Ergebnis kommt der
Waldzustandsbericht des
bundesagraministeriums Grund dafür sein
vor allem Trockenheit und hohe
Temperaturen der waldleide unter den
Folgen der Klimakrise erklärte
Landwirtschaftsminister Özdemir der
Hebung zeige weiteren Handlungsbedarf es
brauche Mischwald statt Monokulturen
mehr zu Bedeutung der Wälder für unser
Klima gleich im Wetter
insgesamt sieben Produktionen der
zdf-familie erhalten in diesem Jahr den
renommierten Grimme-Preis darunter unter
anderem das ZDF Magazin Royal das laut
Jury mit journalistischer Recherche und
unterhaltsame Aufarbeitung überzeugte
ebenfalls ausgezeichnet wird der
Historienfilm die Wannseekonferenz über
das Treffen von Nazi funktionieren die
die Ermordung der Juden in Europa
planten sowie die Drama Serie Safe von
Caroline Link über das Thema
Kindertherapie
Glückwunsch an alle ausgezeichneten und
viel preiswürdiges läuft Dienstag auch
nach uns bei 37 Grad heute eine
eindrückliche Reportage über
Deutschlands Kinderkliniken wo gerade
die kleinsten und schwächsten aller
Patienten auf Behandlung warten müssen
wir hier sagen danke für Ihr Interesse
und gegen 0.30 gibt es unser heute
journal Update mit Nazan göktemir
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der neue
Waldzustandsbericht zeigt die Wälder in
Deutschland leiden massiv unter der Erde
Erhitzung dabei sind sie sehr wichtige
Ökosysteme und funktionieren unter
anderem wie eine natürliche Klimaanlage
besonders an heißen Sommertagen kann es
im Wald bis zu 10 Grad kühler als in
Städten sein eine entscheidende Rolle
spielt die Verdunstung regnet es saugt
der Waldboden Niederschlag wie ein
Schwamm auf über die Wurzeln nimmt der
Baum gespeichertes Wasser wieder auf
leitet es hinauf zu den Kronen wo es
dann über Blätter und Nadeln verdunstet
Feuchtigkeit kühlt dabei die Umgebung
ein großer Laubbaum gibt an warmen Tagen
hunderte Liter in die Atmosphäre ab
und in den nächsten Tagen gibt es
weiteren Regen in der Nacht zieht dieser
Regen erst einmal im Osten ab und dann
wird es allmählich Trockner von
Südwesten her die Temperaturen gehen
zurück auf zwei Grad an den Alpen und
neuen Grads am Niederrhein ja und morgen
gibt es erst einmal im Süden
Sonnenschein ansonsten auch nach Norden
in ein bisschen Sonne aber im
Tagesverlauf kommt dann von Südwesten
her neue Bewirkung auf und es regnet
dabei frisst auch der Winter auf
Richtung Nordsee ist es sogar stürmisch
ja und die Temperaturen erreichen
höchste Werte bis 20 Grad im Süden 18 im
Osten und 10 Grad Richtung
Schleswig-Holstein schauen und Gewitter
gibt es in den nächsten Tagen weiterhin
zum Beispiel am Donnerstag im Norden
Gewitter 11 bis 20 Grad Freitag sogar
Sturm dann und auch Gewitter und auch
Samstag ist es ziemlich ruppig ein
schöner Abend